In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for July 21st, on which we commemorate, the holy martyr
Victor of Marseille.
This victorious athlete of Christ was born into a noble family in the city of Marseille during
the 3rd century.
During the career of arms, he served the emperor with valor and loyalty.
But when Maximian visited Marseille, circa 388, with the aim of persecuting the Christians,
Victor, instead of concealing his faith, refused to receive his pay, and set himself to encourage
his companions in arms, Christians as he was, not to fear them that kill the body, but
to be found worthy of the heavenly trophies.
Day and night he went from house to house to exhort the faithful to battle for the faith,
and went with the martyrs right to the scaffold.
And in his return he was taken before the emperor, loaded with chains.
Remaining immovable in the face both of threats and fraudulent promises by the tyrant, he
confounded the vain cult of the idols, proclaiming that Christ is the one true God.
The emperor had him dragged through the streets, exposed to the blows and insults of the people,
but after this trial the saint proclaimed his faith the more strongly, stretched on a
rack for them to lacerate his flesh.
The Lord appeared to him, holding across in his hand, and promised him an immortal crown.
On the following night three angels having appeared in his cell, his warders, Alexander,
and Genus, and Felicianos, struck by his resplendent sight, were converted.
They received holy baptism and died as martyrs before their master.
Three days later, Saint Victor appeared again before the tribunal, and kicked over a statue
of Jupiter that the tyrant was trying to make him worship.
Maximian, infuri, had his foot cut off, and then ordered that the saint be put under a
millstone and milled as Christ's wheat.
But the instrument of death broke, and they were forced to finish off the soldier of Christ,
and beheaded him.
As soon as the sword smote him, a voice from heaven was heard.
Victor, you are victorious.
The bodies of the holy martyrs, having been thrown into the sea, were found by Christians
and buried in a stone hewn crypt.
The many miracles wrought by Saint Victor made him honored as the patron of the city of
Marseille.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.